of ASG mies it's me Kevin Smith Jason
have you ever wanted to get lost on the
high seas with Jay and salab and now
you're going to have your chance go to
Jay and silentbob Cru esc.com right now
and sign up for jayn silon Bob's Cru
escue what are you waiting for man get
lost at C with Jay and Silent bom let's
do
it
hey
kids uh I believe I'm live uh welcome to
film School Fridays man it's Friday
night I sitting
around uh I've taking care of my my old
lady well I shouldn't even say old lady
the freaks are out I just taking care of
my wife cuz she busted her hip so I've
been in the house for like two weeks and
not out on a stage doing shows and I got
to this place where I was like you know
what make me feel
good answering
questions um I like being useful and
I've been very useful to uh one person
for the span of the last
uh two weeks changed since Chen got her
hip replacement uh but now I'm going try
to useful to a bunch of
cats uh who I'm not married to so I'm a
resource for your kids for the next hour
and
change use me like a [__] Men's Room
urinal
just fill me I mean don't don't I guess
that's a terrible metaphor but I'm a
resource use me like
[__] Patrol found in the earth
[__] turn it into something that
makes your cargo and [__] um all right
here we go kids I'm just gonna
pick so while I'm answering probably
don't keep throwing up questions because
I won't see them while I'm
answering so just a thought I don't know
you guys do okay
man we're g start easy alien Bubba asks
Kevin what do you think about Pedro
Pascal
playing Reed
Richards I like this very much I saw you
know a little
uh uh what do we call them
now not tweets but X's whatever the [__]
I saw what used to be a tweet in my
timeline this morning where there was a
picture drawing of Pedro
Pascal's Reed Richards and I
got be honest with you I got
wet my [__] my [__] got wet that
that never occurred to me what a great
choice um yeah I like it then I saw
maybe Javier BM as
galatis things excite me still get me 53
still get excited about some casting
news and stuff whether it's real or not
but yeah if that were the
case [__] yeah man he's a zatty let's
get him all
right uh orange 2591 says what did you
think of the Echo
trailer shockingly good considering that
you know the internet kept telling us
for months that it was problematic and
Kevin fige hated it and and don't expect
much and they're dumping it all at one
time because they didn't have a lot of
confidence in it that maybe that's all
the case and we just saw some brilliant
marketing but I thought that trailer was
tight I was like [__] okay I'll watch
that um and it may be the only Daredevil
content we get for a little while so I'm
in all right let's see um Richard
kenberg says we need Kevin to direct a
Marvel film you could do it I can't
honestly I I've never had an interest in
doing big movies like that um and I'll
tell you if you know I love superhero
stuff but working on flag fashion
Supergirl for
CW really made me feel like yeah I don't
think I could do those Marvel movies or
DC movies or anything like that because
shooting a CW Show which you know is
a incredibly endangered species right
now once the Superman Lois show goes
that's it for what we all used to know
as CW and stuff um but Direct in those
episodes you had nine days a piece per
episode and by day seven I was like are
we still [__] doing this like are you
serious this is still happening like oh
my god when does
this [__] end could you imagine how I
would have been on the set of like an
end game where they're like this is
gonna take a year of your life I would
have been like are we [__] still
doing this they're like it's day eight
yeah you're you're gonna be doing this
for quite some time so yeah that alone
would like keep me from from doing it uh
but I just also don't think I have a
talent for it I think those movies
require you know that style action-y
style they are action movies and you
know not really known for for doing that
sort of thing and just because I like
superheroes doesn't mean that like I
could necessarily direct a superhero
movie um I'm I'm I'm okay just sitting
on the sidelines watching those flicks
love them I don't even feel like it's
the sidelines I sit in the audience
which is where I came from originally
anyway long before I made films I was a
guy that just watched films so I'm
content to watch those movies and not
you know be like I gotta make one of
them man in order to matter like you
know they got a zillion [__] talented
kids to make those movies nobody seems
very interested in making Kevin Smith
movies I feel
why I think that's will
Wilkins I think we just heard a little
slip a piece of will Wilkins
life he loves his wife it's beautiful um
okay film ramblings with hero 004 says
Kevin when are you and Quenton Tarantino
doing a podcast talk collaboration needs
to happen [__] right like I've been
podcasting since 2007 kids and I you'd
imagine I would have gotten Quenton by
now but uh still haven't um so
I don't know but he pops up on podcast
every place now he does one I think with
[__] Roger Avery and whatnot um I
don't know maybe he's got you know
not beef with me but maybe he's just
like I don't like Kevin Smith um because
we reached out to him to be in Jay and S
Bob reboot and they were like no he's
good you know and he used to love to act
so I don't know maybe maybe uh you know
he reached a place like so many people
it was like I used to like Kevin Smith
but I don't like him no more um last
interaction I didn't even have an
interaction with him but um kids that do
that the podcast Kevin
McCarthy um does that podcast and and uh
all three of the guys who host the
podcast were here at the house uh and
they
watched clerk 3 yeah it was Clerk's
3 and then afterwards uh they were like
we got to get out of here you know a
certain time cuz we're going up to
see um Quenton you know he were
interviewing Quenton for a podcast I was
like oh my God
like why didn't I get this kind of
podcast so I was like well [__] man you
calling an Uber and they were like yeah
and I was like well I could just drop
you off like I know where it is so I
drove the kids up there and dropped off
like you want to come in and I was like
I think that'd be so [__]
weird like he's expecting you guys but
it'd be strange if all of a sudden like
[__] I showed up and stuff and he's
like
what has [__] gone so [__] South for
you that you're like an Uber service now
are you doing
Uber is ride share your side hustle so
uh yeah there was a chance I mean I saw
him at the premiere of from a distance
at the premiere of Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood because the kid Harley was in
it so I got to go to the
premiere but I would love to get him on
podcast really love to get him for Josh
rash's documentary man for [__] his
Michael Parks documentary is [__]
phenomenal like legit
wonderful um but you know it it would
only benefit from Quenton a Quenton
interview and uh would trying to get
that interview for about three years now
so if I had any opportunity talk with
quent it would
be to bring Josh in and be like talk
about Michael Parks that Michael Parks
documentary is like [__] phenomenal
it's
beautiful um study of the man's life and
uh you know it's not it can stand on its
own without a deep dive Quenton
Tarantino interview but
like because there's a smidgen of
Quenton being interviewed someplace else
but like you know I think Quenton would
have wonderful stories to tell
so holding that hope uh
okay let's
see um Hey Kevin says TJ Rainman Hey
Kevin do you recognize how much of an
influence you have on young
filmmakers feel like Clerk's really
showed what is possible for someone just
starting out your success shows what's
possible let's break it down Hey Kevin
do you recognize how much of an
influence you are have on young fil
makers I I don't know if that's the case
anymore um yeah I think at one point
definitely but you know I think most
young filmmakers
or yeah young filmmakers like I don't
know if they [__] with my [__] like I
may be too old at this point something
that I'm really starting to get my head
around
um my age lately like you know I've I've
been kind of blessed in as much as my
shelf life is has been
extended um you know probably further
than it deserves to be there are people
I came up with who it's work you've
never even heard of you know they got to
make one or two movies and that was it
and they never went beyond that and
stuff so I've managed to keep this you
know [__] sherro going for 30 years
in January well I mean 30 years ago we
actually made clerks in January
two three months from now it it'll
be 30 years since we brought clerks to
Sundance and my life changed and I
became a filmmaker professionally not
just dreaming of being a filmmaker and
then being an indie filmmaker suddenly
somebody bought the movie and it was
going to go in theaters and stuff like
that so you know it's been a long I've
been doing this for like 30 years
and I'm shocked that like I'm still
doing it not that like I'm I'm that
anyone still gives a [__] you know
honestly that always blows my mind and I
have no perspective
whatsoever
um of my influence anymore I you know I
know I did at one point
but I don't know this much I do know
though I must have done something right
for the last few decades because legit
every time I leave my house and go out
into the real
world
unfailingly at least one if not
more people will stop me and be like
like they'll see me in their face will
light up and be like oh [__] it's you
and sometimes they know my name
sometimes they don't but all of them say
roughly the same thing like oh
[__] thank you for doing what you do I
love what you do or uh you know know
[__] man I've been [__] with you
since I was a kid like something really
beautiful could you imagine leaving your
house and almost like being guaranteed
that somebody's going
to make you feel good like a stranger
total [__] stranger not like you
leave your house and you run into an old
friend they're like you're the best you
know you run into somebody who sometimes
don't even run into they [__] track
you down tap you on the shoulder to be
like what you did bring brought me
brings me joy and I get that because
I've felt that way about other people's
art and stuff
so that that I have and I feel like well
I
guess like being recognizable as a
filmmaker is breathing rare
air you're not you just added a browser
S I don't know what that means um and to
keep it going for as long as I've kept
it
going weird so I do get a sense though
that my time is [__] coming to an end
if it hasn't like already concluded and
I'm just [__] painfully unaware and
stuff I do
feel
like um and I'm not sad about this or
complaining but I do
feel you know like the world is
like yes and we like we've seen every
trick you could [__] pull off maybe I
don't know
um but regardless like you know
I've I don't
know
I feel
like I'm heading into the third act does
that make
sense um
maybe I don't know I honestly I have no
awareness of the audience anymore like I
mean I know they exist but I have no I
don't know what anyone thinks about me
anymore because the internet allows a
lot of hostility through and as a
creative you're almost
trained it's innate to believe the
negative and seek out the
negative and I've been a creature of the
internet since
1995 so naturally you
know my feelings
about my understanding of how people
feel about my
work is has
been fairly warped
by you know just assuming that like you
see one negative post you're like well
that's how everybody feels even though
surrounded by a sea of positive post
um yeah it's wild so yeah I don't even
know I have no
idea I know clerks is a movie that makes
people who at least at a time made
people feel like [__] I can make a movie
and they were absolutely right it's very
empowering movie um you know not the
least of which because you're watch it
and you're like [__] if this counts as a
movie I think I can make a [__]
movie um beyond that you know I don't
know um I guess we'll see I know when I
almost dropped dead five years ago when
I had the heart attack and stuff I
really expected like the internet to be
like oh
[__] good you won't make any more
[__] movies
jerk um and I was shocked that it wasn't
that like I lived through the heart
attack so it was almost like going in my
own wake and I I saw like so much like
appreciation and love and genuine
affection
for me and and the work I've done and
stuff so you know I
I yeah I don't know I know film Twitter
like if that still exists it's probably
a different name now like the letter box
crowd like you know they think I'm an
idiot
um and I think that for me it's much
easier to believe that like than it is
to believe that you
know no I know what I'm
doing I don't know strange any then
let's
see um
okay the questions are [__] jumping
hey Josh mundal popped up man I know him
I know
you uh Kevin in
January hold
on Kevin in January is from Joshua
mundall um lovely [__] individual who
brought Excalibur to SM Castle Cinemas
for his birthday birday we had a
screening it was great Uh Kevin in
January the pivot man podcast will
launch it will be Loosely based on the
vids I've been dropping on the Discord
called in memory of the wake and bake if
you've seen them what software platform
do you
suggest uh I suggest will Wilkins he is
my platform and software um he would be
the guy to answer that question more
than me um tonight I'm zooming to him
and he's popping me up onto the YouTube
channel there's probably a way you could
do that you you know will Wilkins
[__] pricey let me tell you
something [__] good help don't come
cheap and will Wilkins
[__] it's the most expensive man in the
business um but he would probably be
able to give you a better tip than I
would in terms of I'm you know I'm a let
when it comes
to this kind of stuff I know I'm on
YouTube but uh you
know he's the guy that puts me there
instead uh
okay let's see man
uh Jim TC says what made you work with
a24
um what a great question a I was like
early into the a24
party um
we were it was the XYZ guys um the folks
who were the financiers or co-
financiers um or guys who introduced us
to the financers The Producers they were
producers on the movie XYZ they do a lot
of genre stuff wonderful kids in any
event I think they were the ones that
hipped a24 to it and
a24 jumped in early like I remember they
visited on the set when we were in North
Carolina um at Howard how's house and
they were all kids like the a24 kids
were literally [__] kids in their
like
20s and um you know they had this kind
of plan to be the new mirax designed to
be the new
mirax and uh they were like oh my God F
you know we grew up on your movies and
stuff and this movie so [__] up so uh
you know for me I'm like great I love
their logo that was part of the selling
point for me there the a24 logo um like
The Fray like the one that was at the
beginning of the movies with The Fray
film kind of
thing um so yeah they you know they
were they I they were in charge of the
creative like all the creative on Tusk I
absolutely loved uh the only problem
with tusk was they we had done
a deal with Sony
International
for
uh foreign
rights and in order and it was a like a
big U advance or whatever but in order
to get the figure the movie had to open
domestically on 600 screens or more or
something and you know
a24 was like well if we use your social
media if we use your Twitter and
your um Instagram like oh my
God that's that's we don't even need to
market the you know
movie and that was kind of all the
marketing went through my Instagram and
Twitter and you know it was a great
trailer but they open the movie on 600
screens with no marketing support like
whatsoever literally and I'm not saying
like not enough I mean none so we opened
like
embarrassingly um I I always like felt
after that you'll notice
like I started touring because I I
always felt like oh my God Tusk would
have been so successful if I just toured
it like you know I I knew who exactly
who the audience was like so it would
have been nice to start on you know
either do a tour start on one screen New
York one screen on La but they put it on
600 screens at once with no ad buy no
marketing money whatsoever and ex you
know the only people that were aware of
it were people that were following Along
on my social media and of all the people
who follow my social media not all of
them give a [__] about the podcast and
stuff so you know there was a lot of
people going like I'm watching I'm in a
movie theater watching Tusk by myself is
that part of the experience
like um so yeah it was it was weird I
think the honestly like the last
like words that I exchanged with the a24
kids was like one of the guys was
yelling at me over the phone because I
was I you know I was like why why did
you guys why didn't you tell me that you
were opening the movie on 600 screens
with no marketing like I I there was a
way all around it and then like I forget
who the dude was but he like [__]
yelled at me on the phone and I was
like all right that was it I didn't talk
to anybody over there anymore because I
was like I get in this business to get
[__] yelled at um but yeah you know
so I was I be I love what they've done
since and what they've become and stuff
um and uh if we ever did Tusk two I
think they have the first right of
refusal
um but maybe the dude who yelled at me
would be like I ain't doing no [__]
Tusk sequel I forget why he yelled at me
but it was like it like he came hard out
of nowhere um maybe he was having a bad
day or whatever the [__] but it was
unwarranted it wasn't me going like you
know I'm being unreasonable I demand
things um it was just
like you I just found out that they
didn't have a marketing Spin and I was
like is that what happened
like um yeah anyway that was years ago
um but it that was where the I was like
I'll never not tour a movie
again
um just then I control it
[Music]
um and if it fails then it's on
me not because somebody else made a
weird Choice whatever all
right all right kids where are we going
man um
let me see how you is a Super Chat
question from William Rainey he goes
have to know is there any truth to the
stories about um Hollywood wanted a Jane
Silent Bob crossover I've heard the
characters and Freddy V Jason were based
on Jane Silent Bob and they wanted Jane
Silent Bob I'd never heard that that
been amazing and they could have had us
for [__] cheap um
but there I don't know that Hollywood
but I
remember the head of
Dimension Bob
winstein um was like he called me after
Jane son Bob Strike Back came out and uh
about two weeks three weeks after and he
goes Uh Kevin my wife Annie that was his
wife at the time Annie had a great idea
last night we were watching TV I said
what is it and he was like um you know
remember Abbott and Castello of course
goes remember when Abbott and
Castello like you know they had made all
the comedies but then they met the
monsters I was like oh yeah of course
like Frankenstein [__] mommy Dracula
and [__] like that he goes That's What
Jane Silent Bob should do meet
modern-day
monsters and I was like how do you
figure and he goes well you know we have
the rights
to um Halloween franchise so they can
meet with they can face off against
Myers uh the Children of the
Corn um and uh who else do he have oh
Hellraiser so he goes pin head and so I
was like so basically like Jay and Bob
get the puzzle box and start turning it
and wind up in their version of Hell
which would be like rehab he's like oh
you see it writes
itself um and so I was like no I don't I
don't want to do that I remember telling
Affleck that
story and Affleck was like dying
laughing and then he stops and he goes
you know what that movie would make a
[__] hundred
million I was like what and he goes who
wouldn't be
curious about seeing that he's going I
understand why you don't want to do it
but like I bet you people would go see
that we'll never know but in any event
it wasn't Hollywood it was just that
that one one
cat um
okay what's uh you know I got to I'm I'm
sorry I just
keep leaning into these super chat
questions uh because they're so
colorful uh Todd teal said do you
support fan film showing at SM Castle
Cinemas if we rent the theater got a
great Batman fan film about mental
health we want to screen there
100% 100% I support that I think it's a
great idea um do it up contact smad
Castle keeper Ernie O'Donnell it'll hook
you up for those who are like what is he
talking about uh I own a movie theater
in my hometown in uh one no near my
hometown Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
my hometown is Highlands New Jersey but
Atlantic is now my town because the
movie theater that I own there with my
friends has an apartment above it and
that's where I live and I'm back East so
um uh we do stuff there all the time we
just had the Russo Brothers come in uh a
couple weeks ago and that was fantastic
so
um yeah it's rentable Ernie is is your
guy he runs the dayto day they'll hook
you up but yeah 100% support that man um
that's what we are we're mom and pop
theater come show your movie for
heaven's sakes it's m Castle Cinemas
where the movies come to
play uh
okay Aubrey Gibson says hey cev any
chance at more Clerk's carto tons not at
a chance of the doing the ones that we
did years ago the ones you're familiar
with from um the clerk's cartoon DVD
that we put out and stuff the one that
aired only twice on ABC back in 2000 um
that is owned by Disney ironically
enough was produced by Disney Animation
made by um you know uh 4 ABC so that
belongs to Disney and the only place
that it could ever be shown in the
Disney World now would be Hulu and Hulu
has been like n We're not gonna show it
so you know when uh solar opposites took
off I called my agent I was like hey man
can you call get me a pitch meeting at
Hulu like I want to go pitch Clerk's
cartoon because like it's turkey they
own it anyway and we had like [__]
episodes ready to go in terms of scripts
and all the key art has been done so
like this TurnKey it would be great to
pair it up with you know something they
got going on solar opposite seems to be
doing well and my agent called him up
and uh he called me back and he said uh
they passed and I was like well I mean
but I didn't get to pitch he goes they
they didn't even want to hear a pitch
they were they were like we're not doing
anything right now um
so you know no
home um if it's not there we can't do it
so doesn't mean we can't do h Clerk's
cartoon and Scott
moer um Uber producer Scott moer who I
used to work with all the time and do
smast with um and is now screenwriter in
his own right if you go [__] Google
him man he
made spec script he wrote called
um I think it's Marge V Marge um but
it's like huge guy like Angelina Jolie
in
it and I think Holly Berry but in any
event
um Mo God now I forget what the [__] I
was
even about to answer the tea up was so
[__]
long I forgot what the question
was um oh mo had been like uh right
before right as the writer strike was
happening he was like hey we should go
pitch like a Clark's cartoon like
because our rated adult animation is
huge right now and we could totally go
pitch like a Clerk's cartoon he's like
because you own the rights to a Clerk's
cartoon you just don't own the rights to
that version with Leonardo Leonardo and
Mr plug so that was pre- strike and then
the strike went on for a long time and
Mos is working on some deadline for some
now but maybe in 2024 we'll go pitch a
new version of a animated clerks F's
cross see what happens kids uh
okay uh
um
Kyle midus said Kevin if you could go
back and tell yourself some advice
before you started on your first movie
in parenthesis clerks he says what would
it
be
no um don't let anybody tell you how to
feel about out your
art that's something I've always had a
hard time with my entire professional
career you gota understand I didn't make
a series of films and then one day I
made a film and finally connected first
thing I made got picked up to started my
career so I never really had a chance
to you know figure out how to
process people not liking what I did
because the first movie everybody
[__]
loved seemingly the internet didn't
exist so I'm sure if it did I would have
heard from people who were like go [__]
yourself I know some film school kids
didn't like clerks because of like a
friend of mine was at NYU and said like
oh my God they all hated you because you
broke every rule that we were being
taught and [__] like that so you know
but generally speaking it was incredibly
positive and then M rats destroyed that
like M rats came out critics hated it
[__]
um audiences didn't see it until it came
out on home video now ironically morat's
beloved but back then wasn't at all so
you know I I I made a thing and first
time out the gate everyone said amazing
things about it we were on like top 10
lists at the end of the year and
stuff second thing I made like everyone
[__] on it like barely anyone lik M rats
it was a polar opposite experience from
[__] clerks
and I feel like it was easier to believe
the
negative uh than it was to believe the
positive and I think that's something
that
most uh artists and creatives uh can
relate to the idea
of you know um yeah I suck right I do
don't
I um you know it just I mean you don't
even have to be artist or
creative to succumb to the that voice
inside
that you know tells you you're no damn
good um or to believe the people that
say you're no damn good so you know I'm
I couldn't warn him against the internet
because it's an amazing tool and you
know I it brought
me closer to people than it did push me
away from people like put me in touch
with an audience that I've been in touch
with since I jumped online in like
1995 the vew website had a its own
message board and that's where I hung
out and chitchat with people and stuff
so you know I wouldn't tell I wouldn't
caution my younger self like stay away
from the
internet but I would be like
look I don't know it'd be unfair to
share with them what I know right like
it'd be unfair to be like don't [__]
listen to people because like you know
this [__] first film you make this
ridiculous [__] movie shooting a
convenience store in black and
white with spit and glue and [__]
hope like is gonna wind up in the
Library of Congress like in the on the
the um
protected film list what is it called
the
um film National film
registry it's [__] films protect the
government's going to protect your
movie like it's you know [__] the
Declaration of Independence he just
better hope Nick Cage doesn't try to
come steal that [__] so it's unfair you
can't tell the kid that kind of [__] but
I wish I wish to God that that was
something
I I could impart to him like so much
wasted time worrying about
what strangers say positive and
negative you know I've always kind of
admired David Fincher I met him at Ben's
wedding it was so wild I was like I said
oh my God you're the [__] best of us
um
but you know Fincher makes a movie and
it just goes out and that's that like he
ain't out there [__] following it on
stage and explaining it and [__] like
that on like wait wait wait let me tell
you what happened he lets the work speak
for itself I wish I could be that kind
of filmmaker but I I'm not I feel the
need to explain myself afterwards and
also I like it I like going out and
talking the audience afterwards got a
different
relationship to the audience than most
filmmakers
um so yeah I hope that answers the
question um
okay let's see
man Cindy says hey Kev any chance of you
doing the ThunderCats remake that's been
in process forever I feel that you do
the original cartoon Justice I'm G tell
you right now I would not and even if I
loved it even if I was like I'm the
world's biggest Thundercats fan I'd be
loathed to enter the animated Arena
again with somebody else's property
with somebody else's IP somebody else's
characters
um you know it's
just Life's Too
Short um
so so no there's somebody more well
suited to that I'm not your I'm not your
huckleberry
there uh
okay Audrey Gibson's Aubrey Gib says
please don't wish to be anyone else I
shouldn't say please I add that don't
wish to be anyone else I won't that's
good
advice um okay my God Josh
mundal with a $99 [__] Super Chat
question unnecessary bro but I'll answer
Kevin I'm spending $100 just to tell you
that the first film I saw of yours was M
rats in a theater on shrooms blush your
heart your films have always been witty
and Brilliant if you actually hear
what's being said all your films have
something to say and have M have matured
as you have number one thank you so much
number two don't [__] pay to say
something like that Josh you could say
that [__] free for nothing but uh my
God how sweet are you thank you for that
man believe me I'm not like hey man
everyone lift up my ego I feel bad I'm
I'm
just I like to think I'm kind of
self-aware um
okay uh Z zaku one says Where should new
writers who want to work on TV look for
jobs um I don't know I never got a I me
I had a TV show but we didn't write
scripts right it was uh comic Boke men
and it was
unscripted um you know meaning they
didn't write a script but you know it's
like the boys knew what they
were um getting situation they were
getting into they'd be presented with a
topic and then the boys were very
talented at speaking at extemporaneously
and so they were able to [__] like
weave their own tapestry and then the
ERS took everything that they said and
chopped it into episodes so we never had
a writer's
room we had a writer's room on the
clerk's cartoon but like I said that got
canceled after two
episodes and the only reason I was in
that room is because I wrote [__]
clerks um I don't know I I honestly
don't know how one gets a job writing in
TV um especially new writers the only
way I know how to get noticed is how I
did it with clerks which is like what
I've passed on to people for years like
just make clerks it worked for me but um
not that but more like you know just
make a thing show them what you could do
um because no help is coming
ever I hate to be that guy kids but
like you're on your own I was on my own
like and uh the good news is you got all
this technology your fingertips now and
stuff uh it just makes it super
competitive but don't don't wait for
help um help's not coming anymore
man uh I don't know that it ever was
but that's all right like I'm living
proof you don't gotta wa for
help just wanted to make a movie made a
movie took it to Festival somebody was
like we want to buy it
um God it seems so [__]
simple I never didn't appreciate it I
always appreciated what happened but
like it all happened so fast that I was
like well that was
easy that
nuts
okay uh penino says we love you Kev
thank you penino not a question but
thank you
Sean Jones says can you talk about your
filming of Chris Rock also you plan to
work with him again please do you talk
about your filming of Chris Rock so the
times I've worked with Chris Rock
absolutely delightful uh one of the
first performers to make me
comfortable
with um ad
living because he ad lives a
devastatingly hysterical line in uh dog
when Linda fantino's Bethany says wa
wait Christ you knew Christ and Chris's
Rufus says new him [__] and he says a
line that he says uh a line that I could
never in a million years never would
have written so uh when the T you know
[__] everyone cracks up because it's
a gray [__] line came out of nowhere
and [__] and after the take you know we
were like cut and everybody's like
ah and uh I said said to him I was like
oh my God that was fantastic I wish I
could use it goes what do you mean wish
you could use it use it I was like I
can't like he goes why I was like
because when how how do we do the
credits like screenplay by Kevin Smith
with one awesome line by Chris Rock he
goes you don't have to credit me for
that just [__] use it man you heard
the reaction it's funny I don't I don't
care I don't need you to [__] tell
people that I wrote that line just put
it in the
movie um and then I worked with Will
farell after that on Jay and Sol Bob
Strike Back and there's another ad
living
king um you know Affleck was an ad Liber
as well but I I
didn't take his adling seriously because
like you know I like I made I'd already
made a movie I'd made clerks so we're
making Chasing Amy and he's ad I'm like
don't do that just save all the lines
that you're making up all these things
you're making up
[__] buttons to the scene and jokes
you're adding just save them all and
[__] put them in your own screenplay
one day and he did that and he W an
Oscar um so
yeah
um uh [__] did that answer the question
or did I go far from
it um the thing moves so fast that I can
never go back to the
question um
I think I think I answered that or did I
was at half
answered um God this thing moves
fast how about we try this one
man Zach kle klepser hey Kev what's a
movie you wish you could have directed
or been a part of there's honestly no
film I've ever seen that I was like [__]
I wish I directed that um they offered
me Goodwill Hunting to direct and I was
never like yeah I should do that um you
know I I that that's not it that being
said like
[__]
um is this if you were to put a movie
critics hat what what's going on will
um now i'
uh let me
see part oh um not direct but [__] man
like anytime
any Marvel movie I would love to be
involved with as an actor not as a
director that seems like a lot of
[__] work but like just being in it
oh my God that'd be
amazing um yeah that every time I see a
Marvel movie I was like [__] I wish I
was in that even the Marvels you know
everyone was just like oh my God what a
flop I'm like [__] I wish I was in
that um that'd be good for my brand you
kidding me people be like you were in a
[__] Marvel movie I was they had my
my name was on the M rat script in
Captain Marvel [__] that was I could
go to Comic Cons on that alone like his
name was in Captain Marvel take a
picture with a polaroid with this old
fool um so yeah man that's it when I
watch Marvel movies I'm like [__] I wish
I was a part of that but not as a
director never as a director never as a
writer
either um I just don't think like that
or or see like that I don't have that
kind of vision whatsoever you've seen my
movies they're pretty d basic and
stuff
um let's
see DJ Kento says you ever listen to
Star Wars radio drama back in the day of
course I'm a child of the 70s man we
didn't have anything else I always
thought clerks would be a radio show
could be a radio show especially since
it's mostly one location man you're so
right like I've been podcasting since uh
2007 uh
well I appreciate the assist but that's
so
distracting I I didn't it's it's pulling
me away from answering because I'm
watching you [__] around a real time on
the screen thank you
um I know it'd be helpful to some
but really we gotta help help me stay on
target here um yeah I we've been
podcasting since 2007 and over that time
time I was always like oh we should do
like a movie like you know just record
an
audio drama um it one of those things I
was like I'll get around to it and uh
never got around to it but yeah yeah
there was you know I honestly there was
something I was thinking about doing
we're coming up on the 30th Anniversary
this year this 30th anniversary of
Clerks which means it's also the 30th
anniversary of Jane Silent Bob so I was
coming up with this show that I wanted
to do with Jason all next year a podcast
that
involves scripted
material that we would you know share
with guests a guest every week and stuff
um so it's it's kind of it's close to
that um but yeah I've often thought of
that myself man like oh [__] this [__]
would be good as like you know just a
radio
play
um let me see RM says the what the [__]
happened to Kevin Smith episode of Joe
Blow original Channel on YouTube says
some really sweet stuff at the end about
your career man oh that means a lot
thank you I love the the the what the
[__] happened series they just put one
up
today what the [__] happen Dan Cook I
haven't seen it yet um but I've seen a
bunch of those in stuff ironic I've not
seen the Kevin Smith one I've seen it I
know it existed but I was like I enjoy
these too much to watch this video and
then suddenly be like I can't enjoy this
anymore because they [__] what the
[__] me but it's nice to hear that
they say something nice at the end which
is very sweet I love the Jo blow people
um and you know I I think for some cats
my career has been baffling to [__]
describe from the sidelines
and you know
I I didn't get into this for my career
to make sense to
everybody I just needed to make sense to
me um there's great Albert Brooks
documentary right now that Rob Riner did
that's on HBO Max or
Max um or HB I don't know where it is I
watched it on Max but in any event
Albert Brooks you know talks about some
agent going like you always got to take
the Hard Road and he goes you think
think I see two
roads and I that hit me square in the
head and heart because I know exactly
what he means
like he's like I only see the one
road
um so you know from the outside people
always have a suggestion on how your
career should be what you should have
done how you should have handled it but
uh yeah that's because they see a lot of
roads I only see one road
like the man said uh
okay um Alber Gibson hitting you again
do you come up with the joke first and
write the
premise premise first then the joke what
a great question um I don't know I'm in
the middle of writing something
now and like I got a piece of
advice the other day not a piece of
advice but somebody told them a piece of
advice they got from a writer a pretty
famous writer and you know ever since
I've heard it I was like oh [__] I want
to try that
out so but when you do that then you're
kind of
thinking that's not my original thought
right doesn't mean like you know you
can't take a good [__] hack and Life
Hack and [__] put it to work for you
but you know I I didn't think of that
somebody else did and and they thought
of it because it was how they write big
Studio
things um that are not like stupid
they're satisfying [__] large
scale um you know Studio stuff movies
they spent 80 hundred million bucks
on so I you know that's great advice for
writing period but I mean
you
know the more I become like everybody
else the less I'm
like me and me is what got me this far
you know what I'm saying like they
came because of how I did it in the
beginning and they've stayed because of
how I continue to do it so you know not
everyone has stayed and then new people
have come in
um I've been told I'm done and over
since the first [__] movie there's
always somebody online telling me I suck
at my
job
so you know it's more about
like you
know how long do I want to do it I still
want to do it
um I still W
to I still want to
write and so you try new
things
um you know like let me see if I can put
that to work for me or if that's going
to feel too quote unquote formulaic for
me but as it stands
traditionally I don't I just write I
just sit down I start writing
dialogue that's how my characters reveal
themselves that's how the plot reveals
itself to me it's through dialogue it's
what's being said and then as I'm
writing a thing and I'm like well what's
the next thing you said and oh [__]
that's going to take me in this
different direction I was just driving
around today at one point and I realized
for this thing I was working on I was
like oh man you should do this like add
one more two more beats before you start
escalating and then you know I was like
oh yeah yeah I like this this is that
period of Discovery when you know you're
like figuring out what the movie is
going to be and what the script's going
to be and and you know it's all you wait
you look forward to waking up in the
morning because you're like oh my God I
get to write again I can't wait to
[__] see where the story goes
now um trying to do that while I'm
[__] pack unpacking and putting
my office together um as you can see if
I turn the camera around you see [__]
boxes everywhere
looks like an episode of Hoarders but uh
yeah I I it's I don't write like joke
and then premise premise joke I just sit
down and start writing dialogue and
that's how everything unfolds for me
which is probably why my [__] don't play
like traditionally satisfying 3x
structure [__]
um
yeah yeah let's see a question geek
renderer says snans Kevin snans uh what
movie do you think is closest to being
the most
perfectly
made uh God where did it go oh my
God greetings Kevin where was it oh
closest to being the most perfectly made
movie of all time if you could break
down why from production point of
view um I saw that will uh
hope Grace and Jen are good okay what
movie do I think is closest to being
most perfectly made movie of all time
that's a little that's a tall order I
don't know about all the time but let's
just pick a movie that I think is
perfectly made Iron
Man um if you could break down from why
from production point of
view that movie is as satisfying as Star
Wars that's why when like uh favro you
know made the Mandalorian and it
killed that made sense to me because I'm
like oh my God [__] Iron Man is about
as satisfying as [__] uh Star Wars
is so you know I I think that movie's oh
so close to a perfect movie I can't find
it much wrong with that movie at
all when I say much honestly I can't
think anything wrong with Iron
Man
um and think about it they were able to
build the entire movie Universe 32 more
movies built on that very strong
spine so I you know I'm not gonna say of
all time but Iron Man is a perfectly
made movie an example of all the
cylinders firing at one point man one at
one time everyone doing their best at
one time it's kind of
cool uh okay let's take a couple more
and get out of here I got patient
upstairs needs look
into it's not bad for Friday night
though I mean in high school this would
be some sort of admission of like I have
no life but uh I think I've had a life
um and every once in a
while like on Friday nights if I'm not
on a stage somewhere I think this would
be fun to
do
um Zach says I can't s as a monster
you're not kidding man
[__] the other night I was about to
drink one at 10 o'clock my kid was like
whatat are you doing I was like what do
you mean she's like why are you drinking
a selfie selfi as 10
o'clock that's like gives you energy and
[__] I was like w it's just tasty tastes
like a Welch's grape soda man tastes
like a happy
childhood uh orange 2591 says 430 movie
trailer 430 movie The 430 movie kids is
a movie that uh I shot over the summer
got a waiver from the good Folks at sag
and uh we were able to make a motion
picture very small motion picture at my
movie theater back in New Jersey at my
castle Cinemas so um we uh you
know um will be putting out a trailer
but the movie doesn't come out I I don't
think until the
fall um so it's going to be a minute
before you see a trailer I would imagine
ComicCon is probably the place you'll
see a trailer if we follow the release
pattern that we did with Jane Salen Bob
reboot and uh clerks 3 then we'll
probably drop the trailer ComicCon and
put tickets for a tour on sale at that
point um
okay let's
see um ninj says I love getting chill
here and be in your chat makes my Friday
thank you
um let's see
D 11 production says the most Kevin
Smith film to me was Dogma speaks your
religious
upbringing has a very comic book
aesthetic you're right about that is
there a flick in your career you feel
best represent
you I mean Clerk's 3 at the this point
because it was like stolen directly from
my own heart
[Music]
attackyoutube um clerks M rats Chasing
Amy
Dogma yeah I mean like I don't know that
anybody else in this world was ever
going to make Dogma that feels very much
like a Kevin Smith film if there is such
a thing uh Dogma Jane Silent Bob shke
back Jersey Girl clerks too I love
clerks too that's very much indicative
of I think some of my best work
um Zach and Mary Mega porno you know
Zach and Mary Mega porno I could make
the argument might
be very strong Contender
[Music]
for Kev what I think is you know in
total example of a Kevin Smith film I
mean you know that's not true because
then Jay and telling Bob would be in
it but I love Zach Amir Jay is in it
just not sound about um and not well
Jason Muse not the character of Jay I do
love that movie though because uh it's
about a bunch of people who wouldn't
normally doing a thing do a
thing and for public consumption for a
particular for a potential audience
dreamers you know it's basically the
story of Clerks but with
porn um so there's that Zach andir I
mean Tusk
though is oddly indic
of my childhood which sounds weird
people like what the [__] happened to
you not at all just my father was a land
lover who loved the
sea just like Howard how that's about it
it's the only thing to share in common
my old man never tried to stick me in a
wal
suit that I'm aware of
um wouldn't be [__] up if I was like
yoga hosers that's the [__] that's
the Kevin Smith
movie um reboots I love reboot but can a
sequel really be a movie that
like best represents
you
um and then Clerk's
[Music]
huh I don't
know she honestly this is gonna sound
like such a copout
which I also left off the list as well
as cohort um but um it's generally the
movie you're most recently working
on if you're the writer and right now
Clerk's 3 kind
of feels like the movie that best
represents
me and people like that movie made me
cry I like I like I like I like pulling
emotions um okay let's do one
more and uh and call it a night
kids um let's
see Jose D danillo says when I was a
teenager growing up in Washington
Heights New York City for a whole summer
on the weekends I must have played a VHS
copy of M rats for and then it got cut
off but I get it thank you
man
um did I see shoger electric Eliminator
5 said did I see show girls in theaters
the hype around that movie at the time
was huge it was and I did see it in
theaters remember she's like I be a
dancer in
Vegas that's Silent Bob does that in
chasing aming with Jay's like did you
know I always wanted to be a dancer in
Vegas but she didn't know that [__] and
that's literally a nod to show
girls
um
Kellum one says any advice for a high
school teacher running a Film Production
class for the first time with only DSLR
cameras I want them to have fun but
learn some real [__]
too PS pillow pants for Life uh look
real [__] is uh is um there's plenty of
time for that get cameras in their hands
even if they're older
cameras just encourage them um just tell
them to put their hearts into it man do
something with it tell them number one
don't [__] shoot porn with
it um but number two you know it it
don't have to be professional show them
[__] clerks like look at this [__]
movie looks like it was shot through a
glass of milk like [__] it's not
about the equipment man it's not the
size of the boat it's some motion of the
ocean or whatever the [__] um it's what
you do with it so it don't matter if
it's High camera quality cameras or
DSLR it's what's going to come from the
artist just give them lots of
encouragement some not to hide it some
not to hold
back give it their all
man
um let's
see
uh Walter rosak says please take one
more question please ask me what I want
to ask thank you Walter what would you
like to
ask we're waiting Walter uh Jose says
your chapter of meeting your wife
motivated me to ask my wife on a date my
kids are gonna need to thank you for
being part of them being
alive that's right you tell those kids
support Kevin Smith in his old age if it
wasn't for him I wouldn't have [__]
your mother maybe don't say it that way
but you know pass on the
[__] pass on the that they that they
owe me no uh but I I'm gonna need
support if I keep doing this late in my
career and
[__] um so yeah tell them if they're
happy that they're
alive buy a ticket to the 430 movie
we're even call it quits right
there
um uh opposable to says blanks onscreen
death in clerks 3 was the original
ending for clerks was the his fate
inevitability in your
mind it what a great question you know I
joke that like you know after [__] 30
years I finally got to kill him uh but
it wasn't that was never always the plan
but you know I saw a way way to to bring
it all to a
close in a meaningful way you know
clerks is about birth clerks two is
about
life and clerks three is about death and
um the
audience that grew up with me since
clerks are old like me and we're
starting to lose people so you know
clerks was me going hey man this is how
you do it in your
20s and Clark's 2 was like hey man this
is how you do it in your 30s and then
Clark's 3 was like hey man this is it's
how you do for the rest of your
life um you know so I doubt the guy who
started us on this journey ever would
have
predicted that you know the third one
would be so emotional um but he wouldn't
have been upset by it either because
that kid that kid loved Cinema Paradiso
this this man still does but that kid
who made clerks loved Cinema Paradiso so
I would love to go back in time and tell
him you know whenever he watched the
ending of Cinema Paradiso even as a kid
even in his 20s he would [__] cry
it's a very emotional ending beautiful
particularly if you love Cinema and who
doesn't so if I could go back in time
and tell that kid like you'll you'll
eventually make two more Clerk's movies
and the third one you do your own
version of the Cinema Paradiso and and
it works somehow that that'd be [__]
nuts that would that would Delight him
no end so when people are like guy made
clerks wouldn't have like clerks 3 I'm
like not true I am the guy that made
clerks and I did love clerks 3 and I'm
telling you I knew the guy that made
clerks very very well and he was a softy
so you know that's Cinema Paradiso
ending it exists in clerk the because of
that [__] kid kid set me up for life
on this journey man so I try to honor
him whenever I
can uh I like young Kev Smith you know I
sometimes I hate him particularly in
interviews but I like the one that made
clerks
[__] I'm with the people on the internet
the haters and [__] I like I like the
clerk's Kevin Smith I mean I like this
one as well I like grown up Kevin Smith
but I have a fondness for Clerk's Kevin
Smith because he got me here that
knuckleheaded kid who was like maybe I
could make a movie he was right
so I honor him by continuing to make
movies um so if people are like why do
you keep [__] subjecting us to these
horrible
films because I'm paying back the kid
that got me here man put me on a rocket
[__] uh kids there you go there's your
Film School Fridays man we'll try to do
this on the regular do you have a good
time let me see them Hearts let me see
them
likes I'll
wait m
mhm
MH there you
go um yeah if you like it we'll uh we'll
do it every Friday that I'm free I'm
free on Fridays for quite some time for
this foreseeable
future so uh there you go
kids there's your uh there's your Film
School Fridays your initial Film School
Fridays thank old will Wilkins for
putting us together man bringing us
together um Walter Ros ex says please
tell us something about your mom she's
amazing and how' she motivate you as a
kid uh my mother's fantastic she didn't
really motivate me as a kid though she
was never like you should be a filmmaker
or anything like that um but she made me
think I was
special oh tiger I lost one child before
you and one after you she had like two
two miscarriages one before me and one
after so she was like you're special so
that's what my mom did for me she
reminded me that I had ghost siblings
and that I was lucky to be
alive um no my mom is patently [__]
wonderful but she was not a Arts person
she you know she she made sure that you
know when I was like I'm doing the play
she'd come picked me up after school
late and stuff like that she came to all
the shows all the talent shows she was a
supporter but she didn't understand it
she didn't think for a second that uh
you know oh my boy's going to grow up
and do this kind of [__] there's no
greater fan though than my mother [__]
my mother
loves Kevin
Smith um I got a dog here big old German
Shepherd um and uh my first
fan and probably my biggest after me I'm
a pretty big Kevin Smith fan hopefully
some of you are as well thank you for
spending some of your Friday night with
me man without further
Ado David Oar says you got me through
the pandemic friend thanks for being
you love [__] like that so [__]
meaningful um kids enjoy your Friday man
we'll do it next week for film School
Fridays uh I'm Kevin Smith um
class
dismissed
this is the m greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask keev anything
every Saga has a 10-year anniversary
ladies and gentlemen and this is what
happens with Jay and S Bob get old I'm
Kevin Smith J